interview politique de la matinale pour
comprendre ce qui sera à l'image
politique et symbolique de la journée la
visite du pape sur l'île grecque de
lesbos dans un centre surchargé de
réfugiés
j'accueille la députée européenne et
vice-présidente du modem marielle de
sarnez
bonjour madame vous était sur place à
lesbos ou au mois de janvier à l'époque
les réfugiés pouvait encore emprunter la
route des balkans et se rendre
éventuellement en france en allemagne au
royaume-uni
aujourd'hui cette route est bloquée ces
réfugiés sont bloqués avez-vous honte de
la politique européenne
je pense qu'il ya eu une absence
d'anticipation absolument incroyable de
la part des responsables politiques
européens globalité
ça fait cinq années qu'on a la guerre en
syrie moi je suis allé avec d'autres
collègues et seul voire des camps de
réfugiés à la frontière de la turquie à
4 ans en jordanie il ya trois ans au
liban il y a deux ans donc cette
situation elle ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
ning année dernière il ya eu un manque
d'anticipation absolument totale des
responsables politiques européens
et puis il ya eu au fond cette réaction
d'angela merkel qui à un moment a dit
écoutez j'accueille et j'accueille tout
le monde donc on est passé d'une europe
ferme et à une europe ultra ouverte mais
en fait ça n'a pas été géré ça n'a pas
été organisée et donc le résultat c'est
qu'on sait trouver dans des situations
extrêmement difficiles pour les réfugiés
évidemment et aussi pour l'europe parce
que c'était mal géré le résultat c'est
que le pape françois aujourd'hui va
passer quelques heures à lesbos pour
réconforter ses immigrants pour aller au
contact de cette pauvreté de cette
détresse comme ne l'ont pas fait un
certain nombre de responsables
politiques de dirigeants
c'est un acte politique fort mais qui
est terrible pour la classe politique
et rappelons qu'il a toujours fait le
pape il est allé à lampedusa océan 2013
le mans quatre mois après qu'ils aient
été nommés choisis pas pu donc au fond
je trouve qu'il est tout à fait dans sa
mission mission de lancer un cri
d'alarmé une mission de solidarité une
mission humanitaire mais qui a
évidemment des conséquences politiques
vont obliger une interpellation pour
l'ensemble de la classe politique
moi je crois depuis le début qui avait
vraiment des solutions que oui il faut
que l'union européenne accueille des
réfugiés syriens
c'est notre devoir est d'ailleurs pas
seulement l'europe mais aussi
pays du monde entier le canada l'a fait
récemment très bien le canada qu'est ce
qu'il a fait il est allé chercher
exactement ce que je propose moi depuis
des années il est allé dans les pays où
sont les réfugiés syriens en turquie en
jordanie au liban il a examiné les
demandes d'asile dans ces pays et il a
donné autorisation un certain nombre de
venir et cela ils ont pu prendre l'avion
pour venir
vingt-cinq mille réfugiés syriens sont
donc arrivés au canada chez nous en
europe
quand vous êtes un jeune réfugié syrien
vous voulez quitter votre pays parce
qu'il ya aucune perspective
jusque maintenant vous étiez obligés de
passer dans la mains de passeurs
criminels abominable de payer 3000 euros
par adulte je les ai vus à lesbos 1000
euros par enfant 50 % quand il ya la
tempête parce que le bateau ou la petite
barque comme one chance d'arriver et
vous partez avec votre famille est très
souvent même des gilets de sauvetage qui
étaient des faux gilet de sauvetage et
donc on a vécu une situation terrible et
nous et nous marielle de sarnez
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on fait
notamment la france et bien on est prêt
à débloquer des fonds pour fixer les
réfugiés dans les pays frontaliers de la
de la syrie notamment en jordanie c'est
à dire qu'on délègue notre droit d'asile
on n'est pas gaffe à fait sûr simplement
que nous devrions aider ces pays là qui
nous le demandent
le liban la jordanie la turquie
financièrement et aider aussi en syrie
c'est à dire aider l'onu parce qu'il ya
un traitement humanitaire des déplacés
en syrie et là aussi qui manque
sacrément de moyens dont bien sûr qu'on
devrait n'est pas aujourd'hui il y en a
suffisamment pas suffisamment on devrait
aider à la résolution de la crise et de
la guerre en syrie et la crise politique
majeure en syrie je trouve que nous
sommes absents sont présents le vois
bien états unis et russie l'europe et
pour ma part je trouve aux abonnés
absents de la résolution du conflit en
syrie or il va bien falloir trouver une
solution politique parce que c'est la
seule perspective possible et pour la
syrie marielle de sarnez j'ai vu une
intervention de votre part ya quelques
jours on vous sent passionnés et au fait
de ces questions là au parlement
européen lorsque vous prenez la parole
lorsque vous dites que l'europe doit
assumer ne plus déléguer il n'y a
quasiment personne dans l'hémicycle
c'est saint jean les débats
parlementaires
ils durent des heures et des heures bien
sûr que c'est important c'est absolument
vital on a eu des débats au parlement
européen cette semaine ceux des
questions cruciales sur la question des
réfugiés sur la question du terrorisme
puisqu'on a voté le pnr européen ce qui
compte c'est que les choses avancent on
a passé un accord avec la turquie alors
est-ce que c'était bien de parler que la
turquie la réponse est oui oui il faut
parler dialoguer avec la turquie
c'est un pays qui est évidemment juste
en face et qui est évidemment concerné
d'une chose il faut pas déléguer notre
droit d'asile à la turquie et il faut
pas déléguer non plus le contrôle de nos
propres frontières à la turquie c'est
aux européens d'assumer leur mission
tant européens d'assumer leur propre
sécurité on vous dit eller accueilli
vous induisait les risques on sait hélas
que les terroristes re s'infiltre
également dans ces cortèges de migrants
c'est une faille qui peut exister sur
des lingots tourner vers la turquie
tous les grands espaces démocratiques du
monde ont des contrôles à leurs
frontières
les etats-unis ont des garde-côtes moi
je demande depuis des années que
l'europe se dote d'un corps de gardes
côtes et de gardes frontières vous êtes
obligés d'organiser les choses text
c'est rien c'est la marge bien sûr c'est
pas rien c'est quelques bateaux qui
aident ci ou là mais c'est au fond les
états membres disent frontex tous les
jours mais ne donne pas l'argent pour
que frontex fonctionnent ces 90 millions
aujourd'hui annuel c'est largement
insuffisant et ce qu'on voit notamment
aux abords de lesbos et ce sont les
gardes frontières grecques rec les
gardes côtiers grecques j'ai voulu aller
rigaud ce sont les bateaux des garde
frontières grecques qui vont là bas
rappelons une chose que j'ai envie de
dire à votre micro quand le pape va être
sur place là dans quelques minutes
bien sûr qu'il va témoigner de sa
solidarité vis-à-vis des réfugiés de
ceux qui sont là demandeurs d'asile au
passage il faut qu'on harmonise ce qu'on
appelle le droit d'asile en europe
puisqu'il est différent dans certains
pays on a besoin d'une harmonisation
mais il va aussi témoigner de sa
solidarité vis-à-vis des habitants de
lesbos et c'est important de le rappeler
moi je suis allé là bas et on trouve au
fond il n'y a eu aucune violence
alice bout ce malgré l'arrivée continu
continu de réfugiés syriens à peu près
tous les jours j'ai parlé longuement
avec le maire la population est
absolument formidable eux mêmes sont
d'anciens
réfugié ils ont quitté la turquie dans
les années 1920 et ils sont là ils ont
une capacité d'accueil que j'ai trouvé
humainement remarquable et bien merci de
le souligner on parle de cette pression
migratoire en grèce mais aussi et
toujours en france en une du figaro
le journal évoque notamment les villes
de diem de cherbourg de saint malo avec
des élus de ce littoral qui déplore le
silence du gouvernement et qui n'ont de
cesse de demander une action coordonnée
de l'état manifestement ça ne vient pas
de la part de bernard cazeneuve
vous leur donner raison à ces efforts
coordonnés de l'état et il faut aussi
franchement que la grande bretagne ouvre
les yeux tu dire quand on a des migrants
qui sont là ils sont là quand ils ont un
lien avec la grande bretagne qu'ils ont
quelqu'un de leur famille ou qu'ils ont
un boulot un job potentiel en grande
bretagne franchement les autorités de
grande-bretagne
elle devrait être là aux côtés des
autorités françaises aux côtés des
autorités publiques nationales pour
cogérer avec nous ils ne peuvent pas
comme ça se détourner d'une
problématique qui les concerne au
premier chef dernière question sur la
politique française après ce sujet très
sérieux un sondage auxerre le parisien
aujourd'hui pour la présidentielle
marielle de sarnez et un enseignement
très clair on en parle avec catherine
est tout sauf françois hollande et
nicolas sarkozy en bref les français ne
veulent pas d'un match retour cette soif
de roméo lorsque les lycées ou un permis
noah en raison ils n'ont pas envie d'un
match retour et ils ont envie comme moi
comme nous que la prochaine
présidentielle soit utile clairement
utile c'est à dire que pour une fois on
puisse élire quelqu'un qui avec une
équipe va me vraiment s'atteler aux
réformes qui sont nécessaires pas
réformé pour le plaisir d'informer mais
réformer pour un mieux réformer pour du
progrès et va pouvoir redresser le pays
avec un rassemblement large moi c'est
pourquoi nous soutenons avec françois
bayrou
alain juppé parce que je pense que oui
mais il est archi favori parce que les
français sentent qui pourra faire bouger
les lignes
ils sentent que ça pour apporter des
changements profonds en tous les cas ces
changements profonds et sont nécessaires
c'est pas juste en élisant quelqu'un
d'autre que ça changera il faudra aussi
changer la façon de gouverner dans le
pays merci marielle de sarnez pour ces
échanges fort sur la politique
migratoire et sur le gnr c'est
symbolique politique du pape aujourd'hui
à lesbos e books est présidente du modem
député européenne
a tout de suite avec le rappel de
l'actualité et l'histoire du silence de
la renaissance à nos jours c'est avec
alain corbin invité d'anne sinclair